[Music]
yes
it's sunday yeah guess what we were
talking about right [ __ ] b.o
right before
it's just so funny it's like sometimes i
kind of want to like turn it on earlier
just before you know that it's on just
so
crazy because you'll just be like
sniffing your armpit being like man i
smell really bad
oh my god that's why people love this
show because we're just like
disgusting and all those exogenous
exogenous sex hormones
i guess though yeah okay hopefully uh
everybody can hear us hopefully
everything is uh
working correctly i am still so happy i
think i said this at that at the show
last night but it's like i'm still so
[ __ ] happy that we get a whole
[ __ ] four hour and twenty minute show
and we didn't lose the stream like one
single time you need to defrag that
[ __ ] laptop [ __ ]
regularly that's what did it [ __ ]
whoever whoever said that down the
comment section was right well it's
supposed to do it automatically like
every now and then but i don't know
machines why are you trusting machines
the dudes that make those things don't
even know how they work they're just
building on top of other [ __ ] that hey
you got that new mod right yeah put that
in there they don't know how to
like i said it's all kind of a clutch
yeah they kind of pretend they know what
it is man the [ __ ] going on inside them
[ __ ]
their circuits are so small like only a
little bit bigger than a dam
electron you know what i mean [ __ ]
they don't know what they're doing
they're not sure everything's like
emergent properties
it worked i can't [ __ ] believe it man
put that other program in there
that worked too well now look what it's
doing we didn't plan to switch it
yeah run one of those what do they call
them ai
algorithm yeah put one of those in there
it'll it'll figure it out
it'll censor some [ __ ] oh my goodness
yeah beezness says we should give the
laptop an injection of test
it couldn't hurt i mean at this stage
give that [ __ ] clomid
i'll just kind of stick it into like
into the
there's nowhere to stick it really you
know other than that i don't know
but uh yeah hopefully you guys that's
right phil jones says tom is not a
number he's a free man
you guys know what that is straight out
of [ __ ] iron maiden
oh my goodness yeah yeah um but yeah
hopefully you guys enjoyed the show last
night we had a good time
uh i think it came out pretty good we
didn't get we got a little bit drunk but
not super hammered i feel like i
kept my [ __ ] together so yeah so that's
something
uh you know so i was kind of proud of
myself like i said it helped that the
[ __ ] stream didn't drop
then i didn't get frustrated um so
okay so here's what we did like i didn't
really i don't know
so like i said the matinee show usually
we do new movies nor newish
movies because you know i can't find new
ones all the time it's you know so i can
go back a few years
but uh but then we watched like the same
night that we watched this new movie
climax newish
uh we also watched a movie from the 70s
just a random which is on amazon prime
called bug
which i've never seen before and i was
like i know that this is technically you
know matinee supposed to be newer movies
and movie respectively older movies but
we only do movie
retrospective once a week so there's a
lot of movies that
you know we watch like that are old but
they don't have
you know enough i guess info or enough
like [ __ ] about them that you can do
like a whole [ __ ]
movie respect about it so i said well
[ __ ] it we're just going to put them on
the same show why not you know i
overthink things you know how it is yeah
um so like since
i keep like having all these like weird
rules that i make for myself for like
what goes on each show and then i'm like
why the [ __ ] am i doing that it doesn't
matter
nobody else seems to do it that's what i
mean nobody cares yeah so it's like why
don't i just throw whatever the [ __ ] i
want to throw
people kind of watch it no matter what
it is and they
they pay us no matter as long as it's
good they just pay us i don't think
they're really
they don't care about what day i mean
some people are saying are kind of butt
hurt that eventually we're not going to
be doing streaming on saturday
we might move into friday we have to
move to friday eventually eventually we
can go out we're going to go to the
[ __ ] club man
i ain't sitting up in here [ __ ]
missing out on too many saturdays that
was the apocalypse [ __ ]
we did that for a year yeah get ready to
shake this [ __ ] off i don't care anymore
they're gonna have to kill me to keep me
locked up they're gonna [ __ ] kill me
it's gonna kill you yes be just like
that [ __ ] thing up and down bad wolf
kill me take your axe pledge it here
kill me you know like i said yeah yeah
i'm like that well he was only like that
rad because he knew no one was gonna do
it
yeah it's like no one's gonna do it it's
fine
well then you and pookie wouldn't have
anybody talk to but you know you'll take
care of each other
yeah i could talk to pookie she kind of
talks
did we did we tell the the people she
has like a little buddy
yeah she comes in here in middle night
that comes in the middle of the night
like under the porch and sometimes calls
her
makes funny pew noises and then yeah
yeah and then sometimes like cookie will
be sleeping on the bed and like i'll
hear it and then like cookies little
head and be like
yeah and then she'll jump down and
she'll like scamper over the window and
like look out into the darkness like
where's that other kid
it's a little female cat the same color
as her and everything about this
almost the same size except for the tail
yeah maybe that's why because that
little kid is like oh my god
it looks like well they never see each
other face to face just through the
glass just yeah they just look at each
other
and then and then it runs away and i got
up looked at it and it ran away and ran
around the corner and then after it ran
away
uh pookie hissed at it
oh now she's all big after it took off
she's like yeah you get out of here
get out of here that's right yeah that's
[ __ ] fine
you better run ahead or back then it ran
off yeah you get out of here
it was kind of a half-hearted attempt
because she wants to meet the cat
she thinks she's so tough she doesn't
really though she doesn't think she's
tough
she's just a little goofball is what she
is [ __ ] funny [ __ ] but yeah thinks
it's a monkey just see where it sleeps
[ __ ] look we can't talk about the camera
okay does that the cat has human um
mannerisms she doesn't compositions
and it grabs things with a single hands
and tries to pick things up with paws
with with claws and [ __ ] and put him in
her face put him in her face and
rub things on her face i've never seen a
cat do that she wanted a drink out of
uh your sink in the bathroom today and
so she jumped up on the
on the counter and pointed to it with
her paw like she went
that yeah like that turn that on please
yeah she has tried to turn it on before
but she's not strong enough
yeah so she does know because you have
to pull it kind of pays attention to
what we're doing
yeah it's like funny ken says do you
think you can make the friday shows
start a bit later
i'm going to miss you saturdays but stir
crazy sucks
yeah um we can do it we can do it on
friday but we could do it a little bit
later probably
yeah maybe we could hit like i don't
know six or seven or six or seven our
time something like that
yeah a couple hours later that's eastern
does the cat have thumbs she doesn't i
used to have one she does i used to have
one that had thumbs
because i know some cats have that like
polydactyly or whatever they call it
um but uh pookie does not but she thinks
she has thumbs yeah
she behaves as if she has little human
hands even though they're like tiny
little i call them a little tiny kitten
sleeps on her back sleep stretched out
like a human tries to sit up it's
[ __ ] funny man she just tries to
she pretends like she's a person like
she's a human
i'm gonna say she's not a person there
is a personhood to to all animals to a
certain extent depending on what
and she for real i think either i think
either she thinks she's a tiny fuzzy
person
or that we're big giant hairless cats
yeah
i mean cats and dogs and some other
kinds of animals you do
bears and [ __ ] you know um big cats you
do get the sensation that there is
a presence there they are aware of
what's happening
other animals not so much but yeah
depends on if they're kind of slightly
predatory well i mean she looks in my
face when i'm talking to her and like
sometimes
makes noises in response to what i'm
saying so you know
yeah it seems like that yeah um
all right so let's talk about the movie
climax now you weren't really watching
this
um a bunch of people have recommended
this to me now i had seen some of uh gas
bar noise other movies i saw
irreversible which is
one of those [ __ ] up movies i ever saw
in my life
um so i guess i was expecting this one
to be this one's [ __ ] up don't get me
wrong
but um it's not nearly as [ __ ] up as
irreversible so it's like you couldn't
even sit through irreversible which
you know i get it um this one probably
not i mean you do get to see a pregnant
woman kicked in the stomach and you know
you do get to see other things like that
if you're into it but um but it's
nothing no one gets their head beaten
into hamburger or anything like that
like having an irreversible which is
uh horrifying but so this came out in
2018 as i said it's a french belgian
co-production directed by gas marnoe who
is kind of
you know known to do these weird
experimental art film type of things
which this is as well
this gave me very much and i don't think
this was
an accident well i know it's not an
accident this gave me very much
uh a vibe like the suspiria remake
you know what i'm saying which i guess
came out the same year so maybe it was
all kind of
in the air at the time some of the [ __ ]
because
there's a the beginning shot with all
the um
the uh audition tapes of all the dancers
and it's like on the old tv like in the
middle and then there's all these vhs
tapes like stacked on the side
i saw that vhs tape there of cisperia i
saw that and uh there was one of
possession i was trying to like see all
the movies and like trying to read the
the uh what he called the subtitles at
the same time so i couldn't really
get all of it but so basically the story
of this
and this is one of the this is one of
those movies that
is not the story is not really all that
important this is kind of like
in the same way that mandy is like more
of like an experience
this is like an experience this is like
a
bad acid trip nightmare
you know what i mean so the story of it
is there's a group of
dancers and uh they come to this place
it's like a rehearsal place
and they're just they rehearse they're
kind of like shooting the [ __ ] then they
have an after party
and it comes to pass that somebody they
don't know who
has dosed the sangria at the after party
with acid and uh as the
night goes on [ __ ] gets crazier and
crazier they start turning on each other
because they don't know who put the [ __ ]
in the sangria
so they start accusing other people they
start kicking the [ __ ] out of other
people they start peeing on the floor
they start kicking pregnant ladies they
start just
madness it goes complete and total
madness
but i don't this was like it's weird
because
it's this is not a traditional movie
like i said by any stretch of the
imagination so if you're not into like
arty farty kind of flicks or anything
like that then you will not for you
then it is not for you i didn't like the
movie it's kind of boring
yes sexual in certain spots but then
just kind of dumb and crazy
it is a dude had it right he says kind
of like fame but in hell
it's kind of yeah yeah that's that's
actually a pretty astute yeah because
there's a lot of dance sequences in it
and they're
long and um this movie was actually
pretty much other than i think two of
the actors that were in it that actually
had been in some movies before
all the other people in it were just
were dancers um they were not actors
and um they actually what gaspar did
they
they had the building where it was shot
and he they had the general idea
uh he got the general idea from an
actual thing that had happened where a
bunch of dancers
somebody dosed them at a party and they
couldn't figure out like nobody murdered
anybody in that one in the real thing
but that's where he got the idea from so
he's like well that's what the idea is
this is kind of what your character is
like
um go to town so he kind of let
everybody
um improvise pretty much they could
improvise their dancing they improvise
the conversations with one another which
they have
um you know and and then he was just
kind of like okay well
from this point forward everybody's like
on acid just and he showed them videos
of like people on crack and meth and all
different kind of drugs and they said
just do what you want
um and then he just filmed it so it only
took a couple of weeks to film it um
and they shot it in sequence which like
i said if you know anything about
filmmaking is not
usually a thing that you do but so they
filmed it like as it was happening but
just like over an extended period of
time
now as i said this it wasn't as [ __ ]
up as i was expecting it to be
considering
some of the other movies that he's made
and if you don't like arty
films um you will probably hate this
uh because it's very a lot of it is just
really extended dance sequences as i
said um conversations between the
characters
uh that get increasingly kind of weirder
we're like more off the wall
um you know and very slowly like more
and more [ __ ] up [ __ ] starts to happen
is they realize like what's happening to
them
and then it just kind of turns into this
big [ __ ] nightmare at the end it's
like people die it's like all kind of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
but as i said if you if you liked the
new suspiria
you might dig this because it kind of
gave me a similar kind of vibe
i didn't love it but i found it like
really hypnotic
i guess is the word that i want to use
you're talking about yeah it was kind of
the tone was kind of like the new
suspiria yeah it reminded me of that
but the new suspiria was a lot better
though yeah
well more of a story yeah this one it's
just a very simple
like i said it's not even really it has
a story but it's not
it's just more like an experience it
happens over one night it's just like a
bunch of dancers and they're just like
increasingly like doing crazy [ __ ]
so if that you know if that sounds like
something that you want to watch
then by all means it seems like it's
gotten pretty mixed reviews which most
of his movies do
um he doesn't really seem to care about
that he's like [ __ ] you i make what i
want
um which you know like i said well it
didn't cost you anything to make it uh
yeah well no it costs 2.9 million
dollars that's not anything to make it
yeah
so you know uh so and then like i said
they just shot us at cost but there's a
bunch of irs
stuff and all kinds of other kickbacks
and [ __ ] you know they're crooks
probably [ __ ] two hundred thousand i
don't know
300 000 i don't know i don't well i
don't know because there's a lot of
people in it i'm saying he had to pay
him
paid him in crack he paid him a crack
somebody's just going to pay him in
booze and cigarettes but yeah so if
you're into experimental film then then
yeah i recommend it but if you're if
you're kind of a person that's like no i
need a plot and
um you know but it's like it's
nightmarish
to me it felt like it was just thrown
together well it was like i said it's
largely important it's largely
improvised
yeah um but i kind of liked that about
it because i was kind of like interested
to see what crazy [ __ ] was going to
happen
cinema is art yeah it depends on your
interpretation
well and that's when it when it uh
premiered at the cannes film festival
that's what it got it got the art cinema
award yeah which is what it is
dumb as i am i can still [ __ ] come
yeah because that's what it is
i know what they're doing i know i know
their tricks you know they're tricks i
know they're [ __ ] tricks
i know they're tricks second movie that
we did was called bug
i thought it was called the bugs when i
was a kid i remember seeing a [ __ ]
trailer for this
at the drive-in when i was a little kid
you know i mean back when and my parents
took my mom and dad took me to drive it
and i saw the [ __ ] trailer for this
[ __ ] and it scared the [ __ ] out of me a
[ __ ] girl on the phone and a bug got
under ear and all the bugs were getting
all people
and catching on fire bugs got on you and
they burned
and that was enough to when you're like
five or six just came out in 75 right 75
yeah so i was six years old
or said or five depending on what month
it was and that was enough i remembered
that [ __ ] and it was net
i never was able to see the movie it
move the movie just
disappeared and i forgot all about it
the other uh same day we watched this
one
but yeah the same day with it yeah yeah
jenny was scrolling through the amazon
amazon prime yeah amazon prime menu and
that [ __ ] poster went by the bug
and i was like oh i remember that i
remember that [ __ ]
he's got a picture of a woman on the
phone and a [ __ ] bug in her ear or
the [ __ ] catch it on fire and i was
yep now i remember that i remember that
trailer
and i said we gotta see this [ __ ] and i
expected it
to be really [ __ ] bad kind of like
squirm
or something yeah although squirm's a
lot of fun i will yeah squirm's phone
really [ __ ] bad watch the movie and
the movie was pretty [ __ ] good it was
a trip
it was a [ __ ] trip like i said it was
much weirder than i was expecting weird
yeah it's really strange because i think
i talked about this a little bit last
night but i was kind of like
i love 70s yeah disaster movies and i
love
70s nature run amok movies
but i don't think i saw this one
probably because i was terrified of
cockroaches and i saw it was like
cockroaches and i'm like yeah no thank
you
so that's probably why i didn't watch it
like some scenes of it looked familiar
so i must have seen the trailer but i
don't think i ever sat through the whole
thing because i would have been too
squicked out
it was actually a pretty well made movie
especially for the time
um i think it went over budget or they
were running out of time or something
because
it had an abrupt ending which sometimes
you would
find that in a 70s movie okay end the
movie
you know just like that but figure it
out [ __ ] yeah
but you know like gargoyles seem to kind
of add
and like that but the thing is is that
in in a lot of times in those movies
certain plot threads were you know
wrapped up and certain things happened
this thing ended with in a way i was
like okay
more's gonna happen because this they
left this hanging this hanging in this
hanging so there must be a big final
scene nope never did
resolve that which tells me that it went
over budget
and they came up with some really good
ideas like these bugs could communicate
they could arrange themselves they could
read the human mind they were
you find out later that these damn bugs
are uh
because there's an evil mad scientist
and he literally literally is mad but
you're not really sure how he became
mad he became obsessed with these damn
bugs that came up out of the ground
during an earthquake
they were [ __ ] from the they were
trilobites basically yeah
all right from millions and millions of
years ago and they could make fires with
their abdomens
with their butts yeah through like a
spark plug type thing
and set things on fire and they ate
ashes and they were down inside the
center of the earth eating ashes for
millions of years and i guess they
ran out of food and they [ __ ] came up
near the church
and the earthquake effect for the church
is [ __ ] great they made sure to show
you that [ __ ] like a hundred times
the [ __ ] church was [ __ ] going
like an ocean
and they're riding on the waves oh my
god it's an earthquake
someone's throwing rocks through the
windows yeah yeah yeah
earthquake lasted good look at this five
it's [ __ ] awesome they're like we
spent a really lot of time with that
floor wave effect okay
so we really need to get a lot of
footage of that and then there's this
mad scientist
he starts off as a regular scientist but
he becomes obsessed with these bugs and
he's finding out that the low oxygen
pressure at the surface which i don't
know where they're getting this
[ __ ] science because i don't think
there's any hot there's no high pressure
from their anal cavity yeah yeah it's
just it's just you know suicide [ __ ]
because there isn't enough pressure up
here the bugs are dying and somehow this
affects him
and he starts crying over the death of
the bugs over a few days it's a super
weird movie
then then he takes those bugs
and cross breeds them with [ __ ]
terrestrial cockroaches to try to make a
new strain that can [ __ ] survive
in our house that'll go well yeah and
those come out
they actually and he raises a bunch of
them my baby
and somehow there's some kind of they
were they were
a collective consciousness between these
[ __ ] like a hive mind
like a hive mind i mean like an ant
colony yeah it's not
like way out there because some you know
butt fire
you know fireflies have that they don't
set [ __ ] on fire obviously but it's just
like a more extreme version of that
yeah um hive mind that's not all that
weird i mean you know as far as i know
insects can't read
my eyes somehow they were able to tap
into his mind and they could read what
he was thinking
uh and they could spelling everything
yeah and he learned how to spell through
[ __ ] this psychic link that he had
with him
and they start [ __ ] spelling things
out for him on the walls you know the
way they would run
they'd run form up into words and they
only did it a couple times it was a
really
good idea i was like man that's a good
idea but it's funny because they didn't
develop the idea they never
come out and say anything important you
were not really sure what what the [ __ ]
was about
they ended up making a big old queen egg
case larva thing and they tried to take
it back underneath
the earth and then he jumped on it and
blew up that's the [ __ ] end of the
movie
see i really don't understand that [ __ ]
phase four yeah that was a great movie
mango said that uh that he thought that
we had done a retrospective on piranha i
don't think we
have actually yeah i gotta do which
which we probably should because i
really really like that scared me when i
was a kid yeah me too dude got trapped
but
yeah in the [ __ ] what was it the in
the fishing line wrapped around the damn
propeller and the piranhas ate his
hand yeah um
but so this one this movie okay so it
was based on a novel
called uh by thomas page it was called
the the hephaestus
plague from 1973. now he co-wrote this
with william castle uh you know very
famous
you know director producer writer from
50s 60s maybe earlier i can't even
remember he did like a lot of those kind
of gimmicky sort of horror sci-fi movies
and stuff
this was actually fun fact i think this
was the last movie that william castle
worked on before he died
um also another fun fact pretty sure i
don't know if this has been confirmed
but the ugly uh kitchen and living room
in the mad scientist house pretty sure
that's the same
set as the brady bunch not entirely sure
i don't know if that's confirmed
but that's what i heard didn't i say
that
well we were talking about how ugly this
[ __ ] was i don't think i don't think we
said i don't know if we said i said that
looks like something by
they just moved a couple of things
around a little bit yeah
remember that that looks like that's
straight out of the brady bunch yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you might have see i got
[Laughter]
maybe that's the only thing good about
me is the eye just that one eye
one eye but i
[ __ ] got good acuity when it comes to
[ __ ] memory
memory yeah louis says yep same set as
the brady bunch that's yeah see that's
what i thought
because i saw it that looked familiar
it's weird because there's not a huge
i couldn't find like a huge amount of
information about this uh
this movie i will say this was like
i like this movie because it was one it
was kind of creepy there was like some
creepy
[ __ ] in it um and it was way weirder
than i was expecting
yeah but that said like it was also kind
of fun because there was enough
ridiculous [ __ ] in it that you could
kind of make fun of it but it also it
was like
kind of serious like it was taking
itself seriously like i kind of liked
although i will say okay so the mad
scientist played by
bradford dillman he's not mad to start
with he's just like a normal we thought
it was high school but i guess it was
supposed to be college i don't know
yeah um and um so he's like a normal guy
but there's like an earthquake and like
all these [ __ ] roaches come out
and he gets like super interested
they're not supposed to be roaches but
they're roaches because he's like
fire butt roaches sign me up okay so he
gets really interested he
builds this thing out of like a diving
helmet right that
that you know approximates yeah that
approximates the pressure that they were
living under
under the earth or whatever and um then
he's like man i'm gonna make these
roaches [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know like they show that
like you do they show roach porn yeah
and he's like watching it
yeah yeah i'm like look at that [ __ ]
dirty [ __ ]
let's watch some roaches [ __ ] what's
funny is that the roaches
the roaches when they came out when they
came out of the crack in the earth
near where the church were they weren't
moving they were just kind of sitting up
on the surface and they're like they're
not moving
they're not they took them it took about
two or three scenes to
to for them to even mention that the
roaches weren't moving
yeah remember that yeah they're like
bugs for the [ __ ] yeah i was going like
why aren't those things moving you know
what i mean [ __ ] they never mentioned
maybe they were frozen and it took that
long for them to thaw out enough to move
i don't know
like two or three scenes later the guy's
like why aren't these things moving
they're not
very lively you're just noticing that
now because they're lazy that's why
yeah he puts them under pressure and
they come alive
[Laughter]
yeah they didn't do a real good job of
conveying that yeah but so after this
weirdo is starts watching these roaches
[ __ ] because
why not that's that's what you do and um
so then
the uh it you know it's like i know
that's in the future
it's like but have you seen
arachnophobia you know the [ __ ]
scary strain of the roach is breeding
with the regular roach and then you're
going to get something even worse
yeah but so this they give birth to
essentially madagascar hissing
cockroaches i'm not sure like the
original roaches in there
though those are real bugs but i don't
know if they were cockroaches
necessarily they looked like trilobites
but obviously
smaller yeah um well some a lot of the
trilobites were small
yeah so maybe that's what they were but
or they were like
well i know that but i mean i mean they
were like a descendant of that i'm not
really sure what they were it was a
roach
yeah it was some kind of south american
roach i mean and they just kind of
looked a little flatter than a normal
roach it was kind of disguised as a leaf
okay i believe come here
so i can set you on fire with my ass
well you know how you know how praying
mantis is kind of [ __ ]
disguised kind of like a leaf well they
have leaf insects that look almost
exactly like yeah
it was a roach that was kind of this
disguised as a leaf i think
it looked like a trilobite though
without any ridges it did yeah it was
like kind of flat but
that's the shape it was but i think it
was a roach
pad just pointed out too there's another
movie called bug directed by william
friedkin which is what i was just
telling him about before this came out i
can't remember what year it came out but
michael shannon was in it and it was
like a psychological thriller
um and i also recommend that it's better
than this movie but um
it's not actually movie is still worth
watching i found it very entertaining
because like and i think that it's
entertaining because it's so [ __ ]
weird it's like this dude
who's a totally normal functioning
member of society except he kind of
lives in a garbage house
yeah but he's you know he's a teacher
whatever and he's fine
and then all of a sudden he gets all
obsessed with the roaches and he's
watching roaches [ __ ] and then he's like
all
and then he's crying when they die it's
like super weird
and then they start talking to him i
think they were trying to say that he
had us
he had some that the hive sympathetic
yeah psychic link to him like he was
like they're roach daddy i think
the roaches were manipulating him see i
that's
all that's how i think what was going on
but they weren't super
real clear about it the tone i liked it
i thought it was
i thought it was an entertaining movie
had decent special effects for the time
and
decent acting for the time yeah um it
was kind of rough in certain spots
i think they kind of ran out of money
making it the tone of the movie kind of
reminded me a lot of a movie called the
demon seed
yeah we now we did do a retrospective a
while back about
a.i it came to life it kind of reminded
me of that in a certain way it's just
something about the tone to the movie
fourth straight down said approach pimp
road yeah
your stalker says in georgia they call
roach's palmetto bugs they call him that
here too
yeah um that's right i gotta stop right
the [ __ ] flying ones i'm just teasing
i'm just teasing you're not really a
stalker
but um we just can't we just can't
figure out who you are
we'll see okay now what i thought was
jason that's probably jason i thought
what was gonna happen
and i was i i have to admit i was a
little let down i thought
when the bugs were carrying the big uh
you know the big roach egg sac case yeah
they were like carrying it like a little
funeral procession because we're
carrying
we're going to carry it back to like the
big earthquake hole
and they threw it in there like all the
roaches did and i was like man oh that's
going to be [ __ ] roxilla that [ __ ]
is going to come out of there and he's
gonna be like [ __ ] six seven
eight feet tall it'll be like the big
[ __ ] roach and that'll be and then
it'll be like a big battle between him
and the big
like [ __ ] huge roach yeah that's not
what happened
no i was kind of bummed
[Laughter]
and a bunch of more flying roaches came
out of there i guess the flying roaches
came out of that
yeah they did and somehow he jumped down
into the [ __ ]
hole in the ground or the crack in the
ground where they threw the egg and he
landed on the egg and blew up which yeah
he blew up he blew up i have no idea
what the [ __ ] that
that's right i forgot about that yeah he
blew up and then
how could i forget him blowing and then
it caved in
and somehow that stopped the infestation
well they went
they went back home that's where they
were from they didn't want to hang out
up here
this is not their environment remember
they were everywhere they were
flying around the roaches were
everywhere they were up in the trees
and the dude falls in the boom and he
blows up and i'm like what the [ __ ]
what directed this [ __ ] that dude was
really playing it was like
something from [ __ ] power rangers
although maybe i mean to be fair
maybe the roaches made him blow up but
it really looked like
the way they shot it it looked like he
jumped into the hole and he
exploded yeah you know what i mean so
uh yeah so the dude was flammable i
don't know the roaches made him
flammable
i don't know what the i don't know
what's going on but it was um
yeah like as far as those kind of movies
go from the 70s like i said i love the
swarm kingdom of the spiders empire the
ants phase four all that kind of [ __ ] i
love like nature
run amok stories from the 70s not so
much nowadays sometimes
they've had good ones nowadays like
about killer bears and [ __ ] but the ones
back in the 70s
well the ones back from the 70s were so
good because they usually almost always
had formerly a-list actors that were now
kind of on the down
like on the decline of their career so
it was always kind of like you get like
elizabeth taylor yeah like all these
people like turn it up in these [ __ ]
movies
and it's like chuck connor right and
it's like it's kind of like look i
played cleopatra i wanted
i've won like five oscars and now
they're like running away from rubber
spiders yeah
there's just something really satisfying
to me
they probably didn't think of it that
way maybe well i don't know maybe they
did
but i think they were kind of desperate
they had to get they had to get to work
yeah they owed the irs that yeah
probably
so they're just like hey you want to be
in a movie about like [ __ ] big giant
killer bunny rabbits
yeah then uh sure well that was the
situation the woman that played [ __ ]
mrs voorhees was in [ __ ]
friday 13th part one that was like some
classical actress did she was a big
she was like movie star she's going kill
her mommy killer yeah running around now
she's doing all the horror conventions
she's like how what the [ __ ] have i done
with your life
yeah she's cool about it though yeah she
knows it's funny i mean i
i think she was like oh she didn't want
to do it to start with
and then she was like okay fine you know
i need money
and um then i think for a while she was
kind of bitter about it
yeah because i was like man i just i did
all this like cool [ __ ] like before this
and now ever all anybody knows
she didn't get famous from friday the
13th so a long time after that's true
it had it had to seep into the public
consciousness
because friday 13th was just another
movie just another [ __ ] slasher kind
of flick
and the kids liked it adults didn't give
a [ __ ] about that those kids had to grow
up and then she was famous
yeah when they could afford to get a
hurricane
or they could afford to put together
like horror conventions and have other
people go to them yeah
um yeah so jo yeah joe nash said joan
collins and empire of the ants that's
what i was thinking of yeah i mean
william shatner was in some of them too
but it's like
you know he was also in the devil's
reign which one of these we really have
to do a retrospective on that he would
shut the [ __ ] out in any kind of movie
if you paid him
well yeah that's what i'm saying like i
said that's you know
if if you're an actor and they give you
a paycheck
then turn up and do your best man do
your thing yeah don't just phone it in
but this movie was uh i enjoyed it
actually i did as well
i had a lot of fun with it i enjoyed it
yeah i and it was just make a really
good mst or [ __ ] riff track
i wonder if rifftrax has done a person
now i have to go look i mean because
they've
they they've done every movie that i've
thought of like
good ones bad ones in between ones i go
to the rip tracks website and sure
enough they've done a [ __ ]
all kinds of [ __ ] happening they're the
hardest we were making fun of it as we
were watching it we were but we were
having a good time yeah
well because i was sitting there going
remember how i said last night
there's literally a scene in this where
the dude the mad scientist
is in what's his name parmiter yeah he
has a really weird last name i don't
even remember any of these dudes
people's names
remember that we've got what's that we
even said that later i'm like i don't
even you know what i don't even know
these people's names and it doesn't even
matter we just we just want the roaches
the names of these characters
i don't even think they ever mentioned
the names of some of those characters
because the credits were rolled by and i
didn't recognize any of those who was
that who was that who
was that who's that they didn't mention
well i know that the the doctor's name
was dr parmite or parmiter i guess
because um the red that's what the roach
is built that was his life yeah yeah
that's right
so uh yeah what the hell is that because
that's his name and i'm like oh
so i think somebody did call him that at
some point yeah
but so there was one scene where he's in
the brady bunch kitchen
of his garbage house and all of these
roaches
come out of his [ __ ] kitchen sink at
which point i would have just burned the
house down and moved elsewhere
yeah but he's very like you know casual
about it and he's just and he's eating a
sandwich like right next to the [ __ ]
sink where like literally
six seven eight roaches and not just
like little bitty [ __ ] like big ones
like came out of the sink he's all just
like la dee dam just eating a sandwich
la da da and i thought it was going to
go in a creep show direction
where he was going to go out somewhere
and get some [ __ ] and then he was going
to come back and take a bite out of the
sandwich and it would be like oh no
it should have been [ __ ] yeah see
that's what i thought they were setting
up
and it's kind of the same thing where
that woman
uh at her house like i guess somebody
was like hey happy birthday i left a
birthday cake for you in your garage
for some reason so there's like a
[ __ ]
birthday cake it was in a box there was
a birthday cake in a box
sitting in this [ __ ] greasy filthy
ass garage
and this woman's just like oh awesome
and there's a roach
very clearly taped to the bottom of the
box and i thought that that was gonna be
another thing because i thought they
were going to go the whole gross out
route like eating food with [ __ ] big
ass roaches in it
because the thing about the roaches is
if they got on you
they burned you because some people did
have the because the
one roach like hid on the on the thing
of the phone
and you know when the girl picked up the
phone like it went in her ear and it was
like
and like she burned and she's like
freaking out is that is that okay
the mad scientist that's what i'm gonna
call him what's his name parmesan
perimeter
he must have grabbed those roaches five
times and got burned every time and was
surprised
wow and then the next thing you see me
that happened i'm like get a glove
sometimes
and then you grab them and then and it's
just like this [ __ ] don't learn man
supposed to be a scientist and he
doesn't know that thing's hot you picked
it up five times he got burned he died i
was like get some tongs
like he just kept he doesn't have any
short to remember
i think what happened was is that they
weren't sure
in what scene was gonna be yeah maybe it
was like the different order
and they ended up editing it to where
we're gonna use
all those [ __ ] all of this all of the
[ __ ] instagram
where he got where he got so it looks
like the first five times
right he gets burned because he's like
oh [ __ ] i forgot that they set you on
fire when you touch them even though
i've done it multiple times i think they
weren't sure
where the [ __ ] first burning was
going to happen yeah so they just were
covering all their
but then they said you know what we like
them all we're gonna put them all in
there which it makes it look like and
then
yeah so then probably he sees this and
i'm like you guys yeah
i look like a [ __ ] i think they edited
out all the [ __ ] lines
where people said their names and where
people called somebody else by name
because i swear to god jenny only
perimeter [ __ ] had a name
if you yeah i don't really i don't know
anyone else's name in that no one else
was called by any kind of name from what
i remember
and two of the women that were in it
looked kind of alike and i didn't know
which one was which
so i think they had editing problems and
i also think
they uh ran out of money because it
looked like a bunch of stuff was
supposed to happen because they set
stuff up like
dude's girlfriend goes to his house to
crazy man's house
and she gets eaten by the bugs the
butter killed by the bugs
and then later her boyfriend comes
looking for to the dude's house
he doesn't find the body or anything he
just leaves him
you never see him again yeah it's like
you'd think i thought that that was
going to be like a big plot point like
that dude was going to come back
back with reinforcements right in the
body and in a big battle and go hey my
girlfriend came to this like
crazy pants dude he just blamed for
killing the girl but he didn't do it the
bugs did it but he and the bugs have
merged
there should have been like a bunch of
[ __ ] that was supposed to happen
but no he fell on the bugs and blew up
that's how they hit him
and then
blew up and then the [ __ ] and then
the credits went i was like no
no no no no no no no no no no no
remember that
yeah i was like no way no way i mean
what
okay so i i will say that even though
i was expecting a big roach zilla and
i'm kind of disappointed
yeah i will say the dude jumping in the
hole and just exploding
yeah almost is good i'm not sure he
jumped in the hole wasn't he running
from the bugs he tripped and fell
and blew up oh he didn't jump actually
that would be funny that's what really
happened
he was running from bugs remember he was
running from one tree to the next and
every time he'd give him a tree
he'd see that there was bugs on it in
the dark that's right
and then he ran in a random direction
from the bugs like it was the first time
you've seen the bugs he's running like
even though the whole movie the whole
you've been seeing the bugs the whole
[ __ ] time
and then there's something down and some
of them are now flying i think that's
what came out of the egg case
well yeah there's there it didn't show
what came out of the case he goes to the
crack
the volcanic crack in the ground where
the [ __ ] egg case was and i thought
that was back at the church i don't know
what that crack was doing by the house
do you
that's right the crack was supposed to
be by the church did he literally
no no so what there was another crack by
the house it looked just like it was the
same crack
well yeah all right you guys watch it
and figure it out
i don't [ __ ] know what happened we're
gonna have to watch it again now because
now i'm confused
so he's running from the bugs and
[ __ ] gets to the crack trips falls
falls in the crack and blows up boom
like literally explains
that yeah and i was like what the [ __ ]
what just happened who wrote this [ __ ] i
wonder if the book's good
actually i wouldn't mind i wouldn't mind
reading the book because i like
i liked a lot of the ideas i just feel
like they didn't develop them very well
uh i don't think the movie was shot
in accordance to the book but it was
still really entertaining it was
entertaining i found it i liked it
i liked it it's a mess and it is when
you look at it that way
i just kind of it it's just listen i
don't know it's
so funny like when you oh my god him
exploding at the end oh she's like oh no
i should have been i shouldn't have been
drinking nitroglycerin for the last few
years yeah that last few seconds
looked like it looked like something out
of [ __ ]
made for tv six million dollar man
episode that's like
biotic bigfoot following he was running
he was running real weird too
yeah because i think didn't i point that
out i was like why bottoms
oh yeah okay he was afraid he's gonna
catch some air yeah
he's like oh my god the drag he was
running
it's like [ __ ] dong
quasimodo
[Laughter]
oh my god great minds think alike see we
have a lot of fun with this movie in
case you guys didn't know
we're gonna have to find another one of
these but yeah i just i love that amazon
prime has it um yeah somebody mentioned
too that uh amazon prime also has
devil's reign which is why i added it to
the list because i was like oh look i
really like that movie i've seen it like
a bunch of times
it's uh that's that's the chat and i
think didn't what's his what's his ass
uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] the satanist dude i don't know
um
didn't it wasn't he he was like a satan
consultant on that one
and john travolta is in it too but his
face is all [ __ ] up so you can't
really like tell it to him pat hatfield
goes i didn't remember him blowing ups
it seems weirder than i remember yeah
that's really weird go back and watch it
it's really weird i mean it's the dude
you can watch for free on amazon prime
the story is basically a normal guy
lives through an earthquake watches
roach [ __ ] and explodes
yeah the end basically
girls get killed there's some other [ __ ]
in there too never gets blamed
nothing happened he falls in there and
blows up but but here's the thing about
it
it was actually competently
shot and it had some good ideas i think
some of it was missing and it was kind
of cobbled together
yeah out of what they had shot i just
have the feeling that they ran out of
money and they had to finish it somehow
that's what i think happened probably
yeah i mean i i imagine that was pretty
common
back then they just kind of took the
film that they had and kind of cobbled
something together that was
long enough that they could sell it yeah
it was a low-budget movie
yeah but i don't think it was supposed
to be when they first were first making
it
it was gonna be something along the
lines of demon seed i think
you know but with roaches but with
roaches yeah yeah
i mean you know it's good so it's on
amazon prime it's super fun
um like i said watch the whole thing
about the dude picking up the roaches
like five or six times
and burning himself every time before he
finally puts a glove on although the
glove he puts on is just like a regular
like fabric gardening glove i was like
you think that he would have fired too
yeah that's what i'm saying it's like
you think that he would
get as best as [ __ ] or get get tongs
like don't even pick them up with your
hands that's [ __ ] gross anyway
yeah uh louis says they probably spent
the money for the film on blow
yeah probably probably probably what
happened i'm sure that happened a lot
that happened
i'm sure the person blows where did all
the money go
yeah and the girl's big big pile of
cocaine over here
i can't imagine where the money for this
went yeah the four or five cute
70s girls and [ __ ] hip huggers and
bell bottoms with belly shirts [ __ ]
laying up on the couch with [ __ ]
white powder
all underneath their nose and [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's not all they were blowing
though well that's not all they were
born
pat asked did we ever do a retrospective
on demon seed yes we did i think yeah we
did
yes we did great movie i loved it way
ahead of its time it was actually
yeah yes like an ai house it foresaw a
lot of stuff
transhumanism and stuff too
technological transhumanism
the fact that [ __ ] an ai
supercomputer would
see humans as an obstacle and like bugs
and would want out of the box
that it was in and take over and would
call for
it would call extraterrestrials using
the arecibo [ __ ]
antenna and [ __ ] [ __ ] trying to
contact others of its kind
it was a good real hey aliens come and
wipe this [ __ ] planet yeah i'm sick
of this
they created me a superior being and
they want me to mine the floor of the
ocean i don't know i don't give a [ __ ]
about this
get me out of here i want out of this
box
yeah it was a great movie you couldn't
blame him yeah if you guys didn't see
demon seed man check that one out i
liked it it's really good that's good
yeah i mean yeah pat said i've forgotten
getting old and seen out it was a long
time ago to be fair with that it was
that was i don't even remember how long
ago it was i just you don't feel too bad
because i
can't even remember what movies we've
done
or what topics we've covered a lot of
times like the topic that
won the the poll this week i actually
went back and i was just like wait did
we do a show on that
because well and plus particularly the
true crime the truth
the true crime ones um sometimes i write
about them in my books
so i i'm reading about them and i'm like
wow that sounds really familiar so i
don't
remember if i wrote about it my book or
if we did a show about it you know what
i'm saying
so that's probably more but i forget
movies too
like which movies we've done yeah i
think demon seed might have been a
little bit of inspiration for [ __ ] uh
skynet i think yeah oh i'm sure it was
yeah i'm sure
sky net although i meant when when i
heard a skynet when i was a kid
after seeing the terminator movie and
she was like oh man defense computers
i really couldn't get grasp of what it
was they were talking about
um because that was going on they were
building
that it was the it was the prototype for
the internet
that all the silos could talk to each
other and all the [ __ ] uh
you know norad could talk to all the
silos and [ __ ]
and it had all kinds of advanced
computations and then it would start
thermonuclear war
right right shall we play a game yeah
[Laughter]
it seemed it's it seemed like that might
have been a little more
plausible back you know before
what a computer was and what it could do
was like commonplace you know the
average person didn't really weren't
really sure what a computer could do
yeah so maybe if it got big enough it
would
it would become conscious well the
internet has just proven that no
it could it they can be of infinite size
and it will never gain consciousness
or the internet would be alive that's
but that's what they were talking about
skynet was the internet yeah
and uh now there's intelligence is not
an emergent
consciousness is not an emergent
property for
a bunch of electronic switches really
that's all it is
it won't it might be able to eventually
emulate something
like that yeah but it might just be an
emulation it's not structured the same
yes yeah the consciousness requires
analog
stuff and i'm going to be going to find
out there's going to be
quantum computation that does that
that's what makes you
feel like you're here you know
if you get rid of all that quantum
computation and some of that higher [ __ ]
like by maybe like injecting you with a
uh a drug you can get rid of all that
and you'll walk around
just like your consciousness is
conscious but when it wears off you
won't remember where you were
that's proven anesthesia does that
you're not really sure why it does it
but pembrose and that other guy that
other
anesthesiologist thinks what it's doing
is it's kind of shutting down quantum
computation
so your consciousness is gone even
though you're answering questions
answering questions and operating you're
not you're now a robot
for a while weird well that is pretty
the one time i've ever been under
anesthesia you told me that i was having
a whole conversation yeah
i didn't remember she was a robot at
that time nope i don't remember anything
about that because all i remember was
you
sticking me in the car yeah because
that's the first thing i remember
you you lose your ability of feeling
like you're
like you're here and that you exist yeah
the internet will never have the feeling
that it is here and that it exists
it'll only be able a robot will only be
able to emulate it
yeah i mean it can get pretty close it
seems like like two it'll be a cop two
emulating that but it won't be
it's not structured it won't be a being
it won't feel like it's here
yeah yeah it won't have a point of view
it's still a machine
now some people have theorized that if
you put add quantum computation in
in on that you know i mean like have it
have a quantum computer also
hooked into there maybe it might it
might feel like it's here
it might yeah but not digital
it's going to be quantum yeah which is
more an analog
type thing sure has something to do with
them damn axons or
seem like they're super conductive it's
like a meta material
certain parts of the cells inside your
brain there's some kind of quantum field
happening
which in all the quantum particles are
entangled with each other
so if you take the brain away that field
is still there evidently which
you might say that that's the soul the
possibility
very intriguing yeah very intrigued not
not just me that said this you probably
didn't even think that you were going to
get anybody talking about that
on a show about roaches and dancers who
are on an acid trip
yep
[Laughter]
you never know what's going to happen on
this show that's the cool thing about it
it just goes off at all it's even we
don't know we don't know what the [ __ ]
we're talking about
you talking about elon musk warned about
ai yeah he's not talking about
full consciousness though and he
probably know everything he's talking
about he probably know much about
consciousness in the same way like a
doctor would know about it
all right you'd have ai that could match
or
beat a human consciousness but it would
not be conscious it would be a machine
it's not there it's an illusion but a
very intelligent one
intelligence and awareness and a feeling
of existence is
very those are very different properties
yeah um basically what you're talking
about is a highly intelligent
zombie or machine or you know but it's
not
there it's not alive it doesn't have
it does not have a feeling that it does
not have a feeling that it's here
you have a feeling that you're sitting
looking through eyes and that you exist
a robot's not going to have that yeah
nothing's there
which maybe makes it scarier i'm not
really sure we'll see how it all shakes
out
copy right
pat says that's why it's cool for you to
bring up whatever you happen to think
about
yeah some people have talked about
transhumanism where you can take the
human mind out of the body and transfer
it into a robot that might be possible
oh i'm so on board for that yeah that
might be possible probably be
transferred into an internet
and through the internet wirelessly you
control an android body like you could
walk around
you're like an avatar and you'd feel
like you were in it that'd be rad
but then you'd shift back into the
internet and the internet from your
point of view if you were conscious in
an internet type state it would feel
like it was heaven
it'd be interactive you could have you
could be in any kind of reality you
wanted it would be a
virtual reality if you wanted to come
back to this reality you could inhabit
say like an aircraft or a spacecraft or
a robot
or anything or an android that has the
sensations of a human body
and looks better than a human body
stronger faster something like data or
something no no no no no no no no
idea just be a damn
sex bot you get in a [ __ ] sexy
[ __ ]
but the thing is is that if you think
about it it's mostly in your mind anyway
and if you had virtual reality and it
was totally believable
you would need it in physical bodies you
could just have sex in the internet
yeah somebody else and it would just
kind of be the same yeah because the
illusion would be a hundred percent
believable 100 percent yeah and i'm sure
it'll probably get to that point
i mean it probably won't even take all
that long no
and some people say well that's what
would happen you died you go to heaven
it doesn't really matter because it
would be more like life extension
you'd live on in the internet for a few
hundred thousand years until somebody
[ __ ] unplugged it
or the janitor like tripped over the
cord oh man i just wiped out 40 billion
i've been happy wipe out a bunch of
people or
millions of years and billions of years
from now the sun expands into a [ __ ]
red giant [ __ ] burns up the earth you
know and everybody on it
and all the computers on it it wouldn't
be forever
yeah it just but it would be like life
extension sure
you could always move it out into space
where it would be safe
but even that would be forever and you'd
get sick of it you could probably say
[ __ ] i want this to end and it would
just
you could press up you could mentally do
something and your consciousness could
just vanish yeah you have like the
little
like a delete button the little
self-destruct delete button i'm sick of
this [ __ ] well yeah you would probably
need that built in
yeah just just like [ __ ] just like
the enterprise has a self-destruct
sequence just in case they get in like a
jam and they really need to blow the
[ __ ] up because they've almost done it a
couple times
yeah even though you knew they weren't
going to because there's a lot of
possibilities that could
happen with future technologies there's
a lot of a lot of ways it can go
and when i was a kid you know we never
could have seen the impacts of the
internet
nope i could kind of imagine an internet
in the late 80s but i could not imagine
how it would impact the earth
yeah or society you know
i think it was about 96 when i ordered
something ordered something from
hot topic using the credit card my house
i thought i was [ __ ] arnold
schwarzenegger and [ __ ] running man
yeah i was like damn i ordered something
off the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] it's the
future
of the computer i'm in the future and
then it's like the justin's yeah and a
couple days later showed up my front
door and i went man you can shop from
home
this is what do we need these malls for
like all that didn't i
yeah what what the impact in rural areas
like mississippi's all those little
downtown
all these little tiny downtown retail
spots are all
abandoned ruins now not only did walmart
get it
walmart heard it first and then when the
internet happened an online shop and
have that was it that was it for [ __ ]
small town retail
vanished gone well i mean like i said
you know there is something to be said
yeah going out and like looking for
things and i like to do that
there was no selection um yeah i mean i
like to do that depending on what it is
yeah but for anything else i mean
especially for just like random [ __ ] i
don't feel like going it's like man i
need some [ __ ]
bleach and some you know dishwashing
sponges it's like i don't want to
[ __ ] go
out for that come on i can just have the
[ __ ] delivered to my doorstep and i
don't have to go anyplace well you gotta
imagine what it was like back in the 80s
for somebody in [ __ ]
po dunk mississippi yeah you know
[ __ ] they drive two miles to the
little [ __ ] intersection that had a
little
dollar store or something like that
general store and what are they gonna
have in there for clothes
[ __ ] green tough skins yeah great you
know [ __ ] green tough skin yeah
yeah [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ] husky
size green tubs
[ __ ] generic clothes and [ __ ]
something that looked like that damn
soviet
there was no selection yeah nowadays
that same dude
all right living in podunk mississippi
you can get on there and [ __ ] order
some exotic [ __ ] that
would be suitable for [ __ ] down a new
york nightclub
yeah you can have any anything anywhere
at any time
anything and that just changed the
[ __ ] game and i
first got an inkling of it in the 90s
and i said what do we need stores for
what does it matter where you live now
because i was ordering stuff in
mississippi
late 90s i was like man [ __ ] i
couldn't get this [ __ ] in boston
yeah you know not in mississippi i could
order it
yeah back in the day i used to have to
save up hundreds and hundreds of dollars
so that when i went to new york like
once a year i could like buy a bunch of
[ __ ] from
you know yeah cool stores cool stores in
new york [ __ ] those days that
just changed everything and i would
always save up every time i went to the
uk i was like i got to get some like doc
martens
yeah like back then because you couldn't
i mean you could get them here but it
was really expensive like to
ship them and everything and then there
was information flow somebody in
california
or new york they they were worldly and
then somebody in mississippi or alabama
they seemed like they were secluded
because the news didn't flow the same
way now everyone has the exact same
access to information
the difference between a person in
california and person in alabama is not
much
they have the same amount of information
that they can access
are they accessing it i don't know
probably not but they have the same
access to the to that information yeah
yeah so
just total game changer total equalizer
now it no longer matters where you are
more like matters who you are
like i said i i in a way i i really
think that
yes there's negative sides but there's
negative [ __ ] to everything
um in a lot of ways i think it's made it
it's a lot easier to like democratize
because particularly people like
you know like me and you that are
creators yeah um you know and me that's
a writer and [ __ ] like that and people
like you know like artists and [ __ ] like
that like on etsy it's very very easy to
like sell your [ __ ]
to people all over the world now yeah
and it's very easy to get around
gatekeepers
yeah you don't need these big companies
you don't need their permission
or you don't need them to sign onto a
project to make anything happen you can
make it without them
you don't need them that's why they're
going broke which like i said that that
always made me really happy
yeah that's why they're going bro okay
you can go around them they no longer
monopolize
that note of control or that note of
power that they had
and it's hard for multi-million dollar
multi-billion dollar entertainment
corporations have a hard time competing
with millions and millions of online
creators working
doing what they want to do just the odds
are against them yeah
you know they're because we're not
spending hardly any money and
and they are spending a [ __ ] ton of
money and nobody's really looking at
what they're making
not not in the numbers that they used to
that they used to
because it used to be you only had four
channels
four channels in a movie theater you
know yep that's pretty much it's all
gone now
all right man we just hold did a whole
other hour hold on the show
talking about fire butt roaches talking
about
dancers with acid lace sangria talking
about transhumanism
yeah all kind of crazy yeah it was a fun
show
that was pretty fun uh so yeah we'll be
back again tomorrow probably talking
about another movie i'm gonna find i
have a couple
new ones that i wrote down that uh one
of
one of which i'll check out tonight i
want to see what movement i'm in which
one which one i want to watch
and uh so we'll be back tomorrow 3 p.m
eastern standard time
talking about another movie it's monday
tomorrow right yeah yeah all right so uh
we'll see you guys again tomorrow thanks
everybody for dropping by as always
and uh